hello welcome back to games my stage
here at e3 2016 hi it's me a bunch of
beards yeah man what's going on man your
voice as well John Nichols Bryce Cochran
thank you so much for coming on thanks
Trevor to us about Dead Rising for Peter
Brown I'm also happier here for once
your beard is the least impressive oh
I'm a bit intimidated but he's young
he's got a ways to go yeah push harder
yeah now I got to do the same Dead
Rising for Frank West is back a lot of
people happy about that and you managed
to get this one out without it one of
the few games that did not get leaked
ahead of time there was a lot of rumor
about it though as well yeah what was it
like having people react to for the for
the first time oh it was amazing like
we've been keeping this under wraps as
much as we can but having Frank back in
the reaction of the crowd when we first
got to see it was just incredible for us
yeah super stoked
lovely proud and let's talk about the
setup what's going on is it will amass
is it in a mall how's Frank doing he's
taking a lot of selfies what's going on
so Frank goes back to will Ahmet he's
lured back the situation going on and of
course you know sure enough there's
stuff going down a little bad and so
Frankel's back and he's got uncover the
mystery he's got to rely on his photo
journalism skills and figure out the
mystery selfies selfies is one of these
things that just exploded for us we
loved it and the selfie mode is turned
out to be really really fun and yeah
camera two solved the mystery and new
zombies new weapons new combos
everything okay so I used are you
telling me that the camera around his
neck has been replaced by a mobile phone
no okay still still old-school Frank for
journalism yeah Frank can't change that
much in her game all right
he likes to stay with the roots he's 54
okay so this is how good 10 years after
the first 16 16 yeah 10 human years 16
game years like dog years
yep yeah he's no spring chicken so how I
guess what is the world like them
because the first time it was like
reacting to this you know cat a
catastrophe that's happening in the
moment obviously people are used to
zombies yeah so what's the mood like
there well it's it's completely changed
hombre
doesn't work anymore and it's a whole
new strain of the virus Oh No which
means we've been able to introduce new
zombies into our game and really explore
that world even further because of the
mall we had to bring that back but we
wanted to explore all of Willa Matt as
well and give you a lot more variety and
a lot more things to do we're really
excited about people seeing our new
fresh infected the newly infected super
fast and well kind of like the Horde
stupid right they will run off buildings
run in front of cars they have no
self-preservation but we are going to be
showing not right now
the Evo zombies that's where the virus
is actually bonded with their hosts and
they have become a new being let's say
okay yeah like a put a Dead Rising terms
the cows of the Horde yes the freshly
infected or the mad cows okay let's go
bananas yeah I know a lot of Evo's that
you haven't seen yet or like the Border
Collies that yep and run around and keep
them herded properly we're seeing
nighttime gameplay here has elements of
the sort of zombies get fast at nice has
I've been sort of removed in in relation
to these fresh zombies yes yeah they do
like to stay in the shadows they like to
stay in the side streets but yeah we're
not having them be more aggressive at
night they're just always there and
always on you yeah and speaking to will
them at the mall itself and will we be
going back to the same mall does it look
like the same mall is it I mean cuz 16
years is 16 years absolutely this is it
a mall yes in the interim has it been a
mall again yes it's been redone they've
rebuilt them all it's just in time to
have humanity collapse just as they open
so it's yeah some of the really really
big mall but we kept some hallmarks from
the original malls so the dual
escalators and all that kind of stuff
we've done a lot of that stuff but we've
updated and it's huge and it's themed
there's different sections that are
themed at medieval area you've got like
a Caribbean Cove or the giant pirate
ship when they put on shows and stuff so
it's a huge mall to explore and tons of
stuff to loot them the stores at Peter
here big fan of the series as well
you've got questions for the guys you
know one thing I'm really curious about
is the different games that people
develop I always wonder how the the
theme in the tone is imparted upon the
creators how is it for you to make
something that's so light-hearted in a
world that should be you know serious
and dour they just haven't you guys
have fun I mean does it feel that way or
does it feel though it's Frank West that
allows us to do that really right he's a
he's the everyman we like to call him
the unlikely hero yeah Joe's favorite
line for him is oh yo he'll do the
amazing move and but he never sticks the
landing right stumbles lucky so he can
do it but he's just not very graceful
he's kind of an unlikable hero in a way
is why he's kind of a bit of a jerk you
know what we've Frank's mellowed with
age now he's 16 years older is 54 he's
still Frank but you know his his sense
of humor is better we have some amazing
voice acting in the game and you know we
think we've really captured what we
really wanted Frank to be all along to
Peter's question though sorry to
interject there I guess especially when
you look at something like days gone
right so like they're also doing the SAS
thing yes yeah I guess you are very
firmly in the ridiculous fun jaunty you
know the side of things if you oh I tend
to do this a lot and they're gonna grass
me about this later speak of a food a
lot so think of it like a think about
the best steak you ever had right you
have a beautiful steak it's you know
serves on a nice you like talking about
cows in your metaphor yeah that's a good
thing about that I grew up on the farm
think of this amazing steak dinner
you've had and that's kind of like you
know a horror game that's like you know
it's like scary and it's really edgy and
you're like oh my god it rising is like
a big sloppy cheeseburger they
technically are both meat they're
different completely you're two for two
on good metaphors actually oh man we
both we live for them but Dead Rising
you know like you to come maybe answer
your question little bit better we get
away with it because it's always worked
because frankly the very first Dead
Rising came out and it was kind of
ridiculous and it kind of set the tone
and we've seen Dead Rising go through a
different flavor to throughout the years
brain but we've come back to this
because we think this is what the true
essence the Dead Rising really is I mean
I guess maybe more specifically I was
wondering I'm not sure what other games
you guys have worked on I apologize for
that but this game is so light-hearted I
mean I can't imagine coming up with
ideas and not just laughing cause all
the time that's dope that's one of the
funnest thing the most ridiculous ideas
we're always going to try first
have you been to Canada that's kind of
what we do
I'm one of the you know wonderfully
unique things about the first game was
the time constraints and whatnot and
obviously Zombrex in the second game a
lot of that was sort of like left by the
wayside I mean there was elements of it
in three are you going to reintroduce
some of that into two Dead Rising four
we're not doing time elements in this
right now and there is no cure currently
in this game right we wanted to really
allow players to explore our world more
than they've been able to in the past
with the time element in there you
weren't able to go into every store and
look everywhere and one of the things
we've really focused on in this game was
filling out the world with real stores
real places ago and that's where you
will find stuff if you see a restaurant
that's where you're gonna find food if
you go into a hardware store
you're gonna find a chain saw hammers
plungers anything that you need in there
mm-hmm so we we really want to encourage
the people to play the game and go
everywhere obviously like you guys know
the game you're developing more than
anyone else but there will be a lot of
people who are saying like oh like I
love that that like that element of the
ticking clock that was there and that
like you know it maybe encouraged
multiple playthroughs or stuff well was
there ever a sort of feeling that you
might want to include it here like
what's the reasoning because you guys
must have a reason why we looked at it
and we found we do a lot of user
research we send a ton of research out
and we do a lot of Q&A with people and
we found out that the people it was okay
some people really liked it but more
people didn't like it because they
wanted to be able to go you know what
you ended my game and I was so close and
I don't wanna have to go do that all
again right you know they didn't want to
have that pressure and so what we wanted
to do is we really wanted to make sure
the for the world was really open lots
of side missions lots of stuff to
discover and let people it's still the
same Dead Rising but we've taken some
stuff away and added a ton more hmmm
we also really want to encourage killing
zombies yeah and if you're under a time
constraint
I'll see that big group of zombies and
you're like oh I want to do it but
sometimes you can't we want to let the
players just go to town on as many
zombies my breasts here taking selfies
as a selfie thing is something we put
together we said you know what this
might actually work and it's really
funny because you take a picture
yourself you move the left stick around
to change your expression on the fly
it's pretty funny and that's become a
huge part of the game I remember a while
back you guys released the DLC for
three that had a lot of stuff yep yeah
was that received and are there any
plans to kind of revisit that concept
people loved it yeah I mean Capcom's got
such a rich history and so much IP yeah
and people love it when it comes back
and so we are looking at different ways
that we can incorporate that in the
future we're not talking we're just just
really here to kind of launch the
initial game and that's the kind of you
should be able to expect this kind of
stuff because that's kind of what we do
and what about multiplayer stuff I mean
it's always been considered a very
single-player thing but you know the
before and state of decay the other like
people enjoy playing zombie games online
with their friends you guys gonna be
there yeah 4 player online co-op
yeah with specific mission stuff to do
and there's your time limit there mister
oK you've got the time limits coming in
there we decided to put it in there
because there are there's time-based
missions you have to get something from
point A to point B really cool stuff and
new characters to play with online right
so one before Frank quests so taking
selfies of each other yeah there's a
white board somewhere with a bunch more
of them xbox want to play PC yes you
guys aren't doing the whole play
anywhere thing are you this is no no we
are still you know we're coming up this
year
yeah and that's future stuff and so
that's certainly something we look at
for the future but for right now it's
not not none of the cards for today so
it's always interesting it doesn't
happen all that often have more fallout
last year when we see a game announced
and it's coming out within half a year
you're aiming for Christmas on this one
a holiday sorry yes make a holiday 27
solid a holiday and presumably it's a
game setter and Christmas you don't want
to miss that yeah you guys well feeling
the heat or have you been working with
every single video game at you know
every single game studio they won't
always admit this but it's always you
are always pedal to the metal right to
the end right because that's when the
most magic happens it's true yeah but
we've gotten over some of our biggest
humps right as you can see in here we've
got the zombies we've got the vehicles
we've got the weapons
we're just now in the point of really
polishing or fining all the way to the
end grain mmm thousands of zombies on a
screen like this
thousands of them we stopped counting
that's not just a throw throw them off
the answer thousands of zombies
on the screen I don't know how we do it
when we do it and you know the combo
weapons are back and combo vehicles are
back and then the combo exosuit you seen
liza yeah yeah you put that on you start
baton cars around you're pulling parking
meters out of the ground you're picking
up you know pirate cannons off the ship
in the mall all that kind of stuff but
then you can combo that thing as well so
we've got some amazing things you can
combo with your exosuit for just some
ridiculous combos that you actually wear
mmm seasonal games don't happen as much
in games as they do in movies and stuff
that's it like making a game based on
Christmas Eve eating into that no it's
amazing because it gives us so much
fodder to play with that everybody knows
and understands like who doesn't want to
fight a zombie Santa Claus I want to
fight a zombie Jesus oh well well that's
a yes
oh really is that on the ESRB snow knows
reference it's right at the bottom Z
zombie no Jesus why we're coming out on
the holidays holiday game oh good point
it's not an Easter game no my Catholic
parents right now are so destroyed but
there's some zombie baby Jesus there you
go got three off all food groups there
but we could think about having a
holiday based game is you're comping
candy canes and crossbows it's like that
kind of stuff happens and that's the
that's something that you can't do in a
regular game for the whole year yeah if
you're focusing on this you can have all
the regular stuff but you get to add in
all the holiday stuff like attacking
someone with a small Christmas tree all
rotted stuff like that it's amazing are
there any diehard references from the
bridge no whatever we do have a Plaza
may or may not begin with a cave yeah no
we have we have a lot of hidden stuff in
there we're not you know completely
opening there don't divulge divulge not
opening the kimono all the way thank you
so much for going on - I really
appreciate a Dead Rising at holiday you
guys aren't getting more specific than
that oh yeah right okay and when do we
see more of that rising for
Post III oh we're gonna be releasing
stuff all the way up to our release so
you you will see stuff trickling out
constantly for the next four months at
least yeah it's right the juggernaut
begins lovely yeah your work has just
begun thank you sitting on characters
talking to people if I get so much for
coming on thank you
we'll be back in just a couple of
minutes The Legend of Zelda Wii U in
case you have been watching on the in
Tendo stream all morning we've got even
more of a to show you here on the
GameSpot sage stick around we'll be back
in just in a couple of minutes